hello and welcome to the session on data
science with Python so what are we going
to do in this session we will talk about
what is data science and some of the
basics of Python as you may be aware
data science we use either Python or are
some of the tools and programming
languages so this session the focus is
on Python
so we will talk about the basics of
Python why to learn Python how to
install Python and then we will talk
about some of the important libraries
which are required for data analysis and
then we will go into a little bit of
details about exploratory data analysis
and we will take an example there of
loan prediction and we will see a little
bit about data wrangling using pandas
which is one of the libraries of Python
and then we will end up with small
predictive model or logistic regression
model which is part of machine learning
and in case you need more details about
machine learning in this session we will
probably not go into the details of
machine learning there is a separate
session you might want to look at there
is a separate video on machine learning
you might want to take a look at that if
you need more details here we are just
giving a quick overview to see how we
can use the scikit-learn library so we
will not go into a lot of details about
the basics of machine learning all right
so with that let's move forward so what
is data science data science is about
finding insights from the data so if
there is a lot of data sufficient data
how to analyze and find some insights
out of it this is what is data science
all about a couple of examples here
customer prediction now let's say you
have a customer base and you want to
find out who are most likely to buy your
product so you can use from your past
behavior you can probably develop a
model and try to predict who are the
people out of the thousand leads or
potential customers who will actually
buy so there may be some patterns that
you can use to predict similarly service
planning so for example you're running a
restaurant and you want to know how many
people will be coming or how many
customers will be
visiting your restaurant a given day now
based on historical data you can build a
model to predict that as well so that
there is no wastage of food and so on
and so forth so these are very quick and
easy examples of how data science can be
used in business now let's talk about
Python for doing data science we need
some kind of a programming language or a
tool and so on so this session will be
about Python there are other tools like
for example R and we will probably do a
separate video on that but this session
is on Python and you must have already
heard Python is really becoming very
popular everybody is talking about
Python not only data science in IOT and
AI and many other places so it's a very
popular it's getting very popular so if
you are not yet familiar with Python
this may be a good time to get started
with it so why do we want to use byte
them so basically python is used as a
programming language because it is for
data science because it has some rich
tools from mathematics and from a
statistical perspective it has some rich
tools so that is one of the reasons why
we use Python and if you see some of the
trends if you'd probably tracking some
of the trends you will see that over the
last few years by thon has become
programming language of choice and
especially for data science SAS was
earlier one of the most popular tools
but now increasingly python is being
used for doing data science and of
course as well as are one of the reasons
of course is that python and are are
open-source compared to SAS which is a
commercial product so that could
definitely be one explanation but beyond
that I think it is the ease of
understanding this language the ease of
using this language which is also making
it very popular in addition to the
availability of fantastic libraries for
performing data science what are the
other factors there are speed then there
are availability of number of packages
and then of course the design code
alright so what are each of these design
goal primarily the syntax rules in
Python are relatively intuitive and easy
to understand thereby it helps in
building applications with concise and
readable code base so the fuel line
of course you can really achieve a lot
of stuff and then there are a lot of
packages that are available that have
been developed by other people which can
be reused so we don't have to reinvent
the wheel and last but not least the
speed so button is relatively faster
language of course it is not as fast as
let's say C or C++ but then relatively
there is still faster so these are the
three factors which may Python the
programming language of choice so if you
want to get started with Python first
thing obviously is to install Python so
there is some documentation there are
some steps that you need to follow so we
will try to briefly touch upon that
otherwise of course there are a lot of
material available on how to install
Python and so on you can always look
around but this is one of the game there
are different ways in which you can also
install Python so we will use the
Anaconda path there is a packaging tool
called anaconda so we will use that path
you can also directly install Python but
in our session we will use the Anaconda
opt so the first thing you need to do is
download anaconda and this is the path
for that and once you click on this you
will come to a page somewhat like this
and download you can do the
corresponding download based on whether
you have a Windows or Ubuntu there is
also downloaded possible for our package
available for Ubuntu if you are doing
something on Ubuntu so based on which
operating system in fact this page will
automatically detect which operating
system you are having and it will
actually suggest so for example you see
here if you are running Mac OS then it
will automatically detect that you have
Mac's and the corresponding installers
will be displayed here similarly if you
are on some flavor of Linux like Ubuntu
or
any other then you will get the
corresponding download links here and
then beyond that you can also select
which version of Python you want to
install of course the latest version is
in the three point X range at the time
of recording this three point six is one
of the latest versions but some of you
may want to do or start with the earlier
version which is Python 2.7 two point X
and you can download that as well if you
don't have anything installed and my
suggestion is start with python 3.6
alright so once you do that
you will be able to install Python and
you will be able to run Jupiter not work
okay so now that you know how to install
Python and you if you have installed
Python let's take a look at what are the
various libraries that are available so
python is a very easy language to learn
and there are some basic stuff that you
can do for example adding a printing
hello world statement and so on without
importing any specific libraries but if
you want to perform data analysis you
need to include or import some specific
libraries so we are going to talk about
those as we move forward so pandas for
example is used for structured data
operations so if you let's say are
performing something on a CSV file you
import a CSV file create a data frame
and then you can do a lot of stuffs like
data munging and data preparation before
you do any other stuff like for example
machine learning or so on so that's
panels Sify as the name suggests it is
kind of it provides more scientific
capabilities like for example it has
linear algebra it has Fourier transform
and so on and so forth then you have
numpy which is a very powerful library
for performing n dimensional or creating
n dimensional arrays and it also has
some of the stuff that is there inside
pi like for example linear algebra and
Fourier transform and so on and so forth
then you have matplotlib which is
primarily for visualization purpose it
has again very powerful features for
visualizing your data for doing the
initial what is known as exploratory
data analysis for doing univariate
analysis bivariate analysis so this is
extremely useful for visualizing the
data and then scikit-learn is used for
performing all the machine learning
activities if you want to do anything
like linear regression classification or
any of the stuff that the scikit-learn
library will be extremely helpful in
addition to that there are a few other
libraries for example networks and I
graph there of course a very important
one is tensorflow so if you are
interested in doing some deep learning
or AI related stuff then it could be a
good idea to
learn about tensorflow and tensile flies
one of the libraries there is a separate
video on tensor flow you can look for
that and this is one of the libraries
created by Google open-source library so
once you're familiar with machine
learning data analysis machine learning
then that may be the next step to go to
deep learning and AI so that's where
tensor flow will be used then you have
beautiful soup which is primarily used
for web scraping and then you take that
data and then analyze and so on then OS
library is a very common library as the
name suggests it is for operating system
so if you want to do something on
creating directories or folders and
things like that that's when you would
use OS alright so moving on let's talk
in a little bit more detail about each
of these libraries so scifi as the name
suggests is a scientific library and it
very specifically it has some special
functions for integration and for
ordinary differential equations so as
you can see these are mathematical
operations or mathematical functions so
these are readily available in this
library and it has linear algebra
modules and data's built on top of numpy
so you will see what is there in numpy
so this is a again as the name suggests
that num comes from numbers so it is a
mathematical library and one of its key
features is availability of n
dimensional array object it is a very
powerful object and we will see how to
use this and then of course you can
create other lesser objects and so on
and it has tools for integrating with C
C++ and also Fortran code and then it of
course also has linear algebra and
Fourier transformation and so on all
these scientific capabilities okay what
else pandas is another very powerful
library primarily for data manipulation
so if you are importing any files you
will want to create it like a table so
you create what is known as data frames
these are very powerful data structures
that are used in Python programming so
pandas library provides this capability
and once you import a date import the
data into data frame you can pretty much
do whatever you are doing like in a
regular database so people who are
coming from a database background
or SQL background would really like this
because it has very different feel very
much at home because it feels like
you're using you're viewing a table or
using a table and you can do a lot of
stuff using the finest library now there
are two important terms or components in
pandas series and the data frame I was
just talking about the data frame so
let's take a look at what our series and
what is a data frame
so within pandas we have series and data
frames so series is primarily some of
you may also be knowing this as let's
say an array so it's a one-dimensional
structure data structure if you will in
some other languages you may call it as
an array or maybe some others probably
an equivalent of a list in our perhaps
I'm not very sure on that aspect but yes
so this is like a one-dimensional
storage of information so that is what a
series whereas data frame is like a
table so you have a two-dimensional
structure you have rows and you have
columns and this is very people as I
said were familiar with SQL and
databases will be able to relate to this
very quickly so you have like a table
you have rows and columns and then you
can manipulate the data so if you want
to create a series this is how you would
create the code snippet and as you can
see the programming in Python is very
simple there are no major overheads you
just need to import some libraries
whichever essential and then start
creating objects so you don't have to do
additional declaration of variables and
things like that so that is I think one
key difference between Python and other
programming languages and what does the
series contain it has to contain these
numbers 6 3 4 6 and X is my object
consisting of the series so if you
display if you just say X it will
display the contents of X and you will
see here that it creates the default
index then you have data frames if you
want to create a data frame as you can
see the series is like a one dimensional
structure there is just like a row one
row of items where as a data frame looks
somewhat like this it is a
two-dimensional structure so you have
columns in one dimension and then you
have rows in the other dimension how do
you create a data frame you will need to
create unique
rather import pandas and then you import
in this case we are basically creating
our own data so that's the reason we are
importing numpy which is one of the
libraries we just referred to a little
bit before so we are using one of the
functionalities within numpy to create
some random numbers otherwise this is
not really mandatory you probably will
be importing the data from outside maybe
some CSV file and import into the data
frame so that's what we are doing here
so in this case we are creating our own
test data that's the reason we are
importing numpy as NP and then I create
a data frame saying PD dot data frame so
this is the keyword here similarly here
in this case while creating series we
set PD dot series and then you pass the
value similarly here using PD dot data
frame now in order to create the data
frame it needs the values in each of
these cells what are the values in the
rows and what are the values in the
column so that in our example we are
providing using this random number
generator so NP dot random is like a
class or a method that is available in
numpy and then you are saying okay
generate some random numbers in the form
of a four by three matrix or four by
three data frame the four here indicates
the number of rows and the three here
indicates the number of columns so these
are the columns 0 1 2 are the columns
and these are the rows here 0 this is 1
this is 2 this is 3 okay and once again
it will when you display DF it will give
us default index there are ways to omit
that but at this point we will just keep
it simple so it will display the default
index and then the actual values in each
of these rows and column so this is the
way you create data frame so now that we
have learnt some of the basics of pandas
let's take a quick look at how we use
this in real life so let's assume we
have a situation where we have some
customer data and we want to kind of
predict whether the customers loan will
be approved or not so we have some
historical data about the loans and
about the customers and using that we
will try to come up with a way to maybe
predict whether loan will be approved or
not so let's see how we can do that so
this is a part of exploratory analysis
so we will first start with exploratory
analysis we will try to see how the data
is looking so what kind of data so we
will of course I'll take you into the
Jupiter notebook and give you a quick
live demo but before that let's quickly
walk through some of the pieces of this
program and slides and then I will take
you actually into the actual code and do
a demo of that so the Python program
structure looks somewhat like this the
first step is to import your all the
required libraries now of course it is
not necessary that you have to import
all your libraries right at the top of
the chord but it is a good practice so
you feel know you are going to need a
certain set of libraries it may be a
good idea to put from a readability
perspective it's a good practice to put
all the libraries that you are importing
at the beginning of your code
however it is not mandatory so in the
middle of the code somewhere if you feel
that you need a particular library you
can import that library and then start
using it in the middle of the code so
that's also perfectly fine it will not
give any errors or anything however as I
said it's not such a good practice so we
will import all the required libraries
in this case we are importing pandas
numpy and matplotlib and in addition if
we include this piece of code percentage
matplotlib in line what will happen is
all the graphs that we are going to
create the visualizations that we are
going to create will be displayed within
the notebook so if you want to have that
kind of a provision you need to have
this line so it's always a good idea
when you're starting off I think it's a
good idea to just include this line so
that your graphs are shown in line okay
so these are the four we will start with
these four lines of code then the next
step is to import your data so in our
case there is a training data for loams
by the name lone p underscore train dot
CSV and we are reading this data so in
this case you see here unlike the
previous example where we created our
data frame with some data that we
created ourselves here we are actually
creating a data frame using some
external data and it's the method is
very very straightforward so you use the
heed underscore CSV method and it is a
very intuitive function name and you say
APD dot read underscore CSV and give the
part of the file CSV file that's about
it and then that is read into the data
frame DF this can be any name we are
calling it DF you can call XYZ anything
this is a name just name of the object
so head is one of the methods within the
data frame and it will give us the first
five so this is just take a quick look
now you have imported the data you want
to initially have a quick look how your
data is looking what are the values in
some of the columns and so on and so
forth right so typically you would do a
head D F dot head to get the sample of
let's say the first few lines of your
data so that's what has happened here so
it displays the first few lines and then
you can see what are the columns within
that and what are the values in each of
these cells and so on and so forth you
can also typically you would like to see
if there are any null values or are
there any is the data for whatever
reason is invalid or looking dirty for
whatever reason some unnecessary
character so this will give a quick view
of that so in this case pretty much
everything looks okay then the next step
is to understand the data a little bit
overall for each of the columns what
what is the information so the describe
function will basically give us a
summary of the data what else can we do
pandas also allows us to visualize the
data and this is more like a part of
what we call it as univariate analysis
that means each and every column you can
take and do some plots and visualization
to understand data in each of the
columns so for example here the loan
amount column we can take and then the
hist basically hist method will create a
histogram so you take all the values
from one column which is loan amount and
you create a histogram to see how the
data is distributed right so that's what
is happening here and as you can see
there are some extreme values so this is
again to identify do we have to do some
data preparation because if the data is
in a completely half of that way the
analysis may be difficult so we these
are Enosh
or exploratory data analysis is
primarily done to understand that and
see if we need to do some data
preparation before we get into the other
steps like machine learning and
statistical modeling and so on so in
this case we will see that here by
plotting this histogram we see that
there are some extreme values so there
are some values a lot of it is around
hundred range but there is also
something of one or two observations in
the 700 range so it's pretty scattered
in that sense or they're not really
scattered distributed at least scattered
but it is randomly scattered so the
range is really huge so what can we do
about this so there are some steps that
we need to do normalization and so on so
we will see that in a bit so this is for
one of the columns let's take another
column which is applicant income similar
kind of similar situation you have most
of your observations in this range but
there are also some which are far off
from pay most of the observations are so
this is also pretty this also has some
extreme values so we will have to see
what can be done credit history is the
binary value so some people have zero
value and some with a credit history of
one this is just like a flag so this
basically is telling us how many people
have won and how many people have zero
so looks like majority of them have a
value of one and a few about hundred of
them have a value of zero okay what else
can we do so we now understood a little
bit about the data so we need to do some
data wrangling or data munging and see
if we can some bring in some kind of
normalization of all this data and we
will kind of try to understand what is
data wrangling and before we actually go
into it okay so data wrangling is
nothing but a process of cleaning the
data if let's say there are there are
multiple things that can happen in this
particular example there were no missing
values but typically when you get some
data very often it will so happen that a
lot of values are missing either they
are null values or there are a lot of
zeros now you cannot use such data as it
is to perform some let's say predictive
analysis or perform some machine
learning activities and so on so that is
one part of it so you need to clean the
data the other is unifying the data now
these ranges of this data are
very huge some of them are going from
some columns are going from zero to a
hundred thousand and some columns are
just between ten to twenty and so on
these will affect the accuracy of the
analysis so we need to do some kind of
unifying the data and so on so that is
what wrangling data wrangling is all
about so before we actually perform any
analysis we need to bring the data so to
some kind of a shape so that we can
perform additional analysis actual
analysis on this and get some insights
now how do we deal with missing values
is a very common issue when we take data
or when we get data from the business
when a data scientist gets the data from
the business so we should never assume
that all our data will be clean and all
the values filled up and so on because
in real life very often there will be
the data will be dirty so data wrangling
is the process where you kind of clean
up the data first of all identify
whether the data is dirty and then clean
up so how do we find some data is
missing so there are a few ways you can
write a small piece of code which will
identify if for a given column or for
given row any of the observations are
null primarily so this line of code for
example is doing that it is trying to
identify how many null values or missing
values are there for each of the columns
so this is a lambda function and what we
are saying is find out a four value is
now and then you add all of them how
many observations are there where it is
particular column is null so it does
that for all the column so here you will
see that for Loan ID it's an ID so there
are no null values or missing values
gender has about 13 observations where
the values are missing similarly marital
status has three and so on and so forth
so we will see here for example loan
amount has 21 durations where the values
are missing loan amount term has 14
observations and so on so we will see
how to handle this missing values so
there are multiple ways in which you can
handle missing values if the number of
observations are very small compared to
the total number of observations then
sometimes
one of the easy ways is to completely
remove that data so or delete that
record exclude that record so that is
one way of doing it so if they are let's
say a million records and maybe ten
records are having missing values it may
not be worth doing something to fill up
those values it may be better off to get
rid of those observations right so that
is the missing values are
proportionately very small but if there
are a relatively large number of missing
values if you exclude those observations
then your accuracy may not be that very
good so there the other way of doing it
is we can take a mean value or a
particular column and fill up wherever
there are missing values fill up those
observations or cells with the mean
value so that way what happens is you
don't give some value which is too high
or too low and it somehow fits within
the range of the observations that we
are seeing so this is one technique
again there are it can be case to case
and you may have to take a call based on
your specific situation but these are
some of the common method if you see in
the previous case loan amount had
twenty-one and now we went ahead and
filled all of those with the mean value
so now there are zero with missing
values okay so this is one part of a
data wrangling activity what else you
can do you can also check what are the
types of the data so DF dot d-types will
give us what are the various data types
so all right so you can also perform
some basic mathematical observations we
have already seen that mean we form now
so similarly if you do call the mean
method for the data frame object it will
actually perform or display or calculate
the mean for pretty much all the
numerical columns that are available in
this right so for example here applicant
income cop you can't income and all
these are numerical values so it will
display the mean values of all of those
now
another thing that you can do is you can
actually also combine data frames so
let's say you import data from one CSV
file into one data frame and another CSV
file into another data frame and then
you want to merge these because you want
to do an analysis on the entire
okay one example could be that you have
data in the form of CSV files one CSV
file for each month of the year January
February March each of these are in a
difference so you can import them into
let's say twelve data frames and then
you can merge them together as a single
data frame and then you perform your
analysis on that data frame or the
entire data for that year so that is one
example so how do we do that this is
what we do again in this case we are not
importing any data we are just creating
some random values are using some random
values so let's assume I have a data
frame which is by the name one and I
assign some random values here which is
a five by four format so there are five
rows and four columns and this is our my
data frame one looks and then I create
another data frame which is data frame
two again random numbers of the format
five by four and I have something like
this now I want to combine these two how
do I combine these two I can use the
concatenate or concatenated and I can
combine these two so PD dot contact and
it takes the data frames one and two if
you have more of them you can provide
them and it will just simply add all of
them merge all of them but concatenate
whatever you call whichever term you
call it will so of course you have to
make sure that the structure remains the
same like I said this could be let's say
sales data coming for twelve different
months but each of the files has the
same structure so now you can combine
all of them merge all of them are using
the concat method if we have let's say
structure is not identical then what
will happen let's say we have these two
data frames one has a column by the name
key and the second column is as well and
a second data frame which has a column
by the name key but the second column by
the name are well not Elva so you see
here the structure is not identical so
you can still combine them but then the
way they get combined or moist is
somewhat like this so it takes the key
as a common parameter between them some
common column has to be there otherwise
this will not work
and then we have to use merge instead of
concatenate and when we do a merge then
we get the result will be in this format
what it does is it uses the key as a
common thread between them and then it
kind of populates the values accordingly
so if you see here the first one had foo
and bar four key and then it had L
values of one and two right so if we go
back foo and bar had one and two L value
so that's what we see here one and two
whereas in the right data frame
we had foo bar and bar as a second time
and then our values are three four and
five so what it has done for foo it has
put for the existing right for foo is
already existing because it has come
from left so it will just put the value
of our Val here which is three similarly
it will put four here because four bar
if you go back four bar it is the value
is four and since it has one more value
of bar it will go and add this five as
well
the only thing here is that this one had
for example left had only two values and
only one value for bar but since we are
appending or merging and there are two
key values with the bar therefore it
will kind of repeat the value of L Val
here so that's what we are seeing in
this case right so L value appears twice
the number two appears twice but that is
because our value there are two of them
okay all right so that is how when you
don't have identical structure that is
of you much know we will talk a little
bit about scikit-learn so scikit-learn
is a library which is used for doing
machine learning or performing machine
learning activities so if you want to do
linear regression logistic regression
and so on there are easily useable KPIs
that you can call and that's the
advantage of scikit-learn and it
provides the bunch of algorithms so I
think that is the good part about this
library so if you want to use
scikit-learn obviously you need to
import these modules and also there are
some sub modules you may have to import
based on what you are trying to use like
for example
we want to use logistic regression again
people who are probably not very
familiar with machine learning there is
a separate module for machine learning
you may want to take a look at that but
we will just touch upon the basics here
so machine learning has some algorithms
like linear regression logistic
regression and random forest
classification and so on so that is what
we are talking about here so those
algorithms are available and then if you
want to use some of them you need to
import them and from the scikit-learn
library so scikit-learn is the top-level
library which is basically STL learn
write and then it has kind of sub parts
in it you need to import those based on
what exactly you will be or which
algorithm you will be using so let us
take an example as we move and we will
see that whenever we perform some
machine learning activity those of you
who are familiar with machine learning
will already know this we split our
labeled data into two parts training and
test now there are multiple ways of
splitting this data how do we either
some people do it like 5050 some people
do it
8020 which is training is 80 and test it
is 20 and so on so it is individual
preference there are no hard and fast
rules by and large we have seen that
training data set is larger than the
test data set and again we will probably
not go into details of why do we do this
at this point but that's one of the
steps in machine learning
so scikit-learn offers a readily
available method to do this which is
drain test split alright so in this
example let's say we are taking the
values x and y are our values x is the
independent variables and Y is our
dependent variable okay and we are using
these two and then I want to split this
into train and test data so what do we
do we import the Train test split sub
module from within scikit-learn which is
a scalar on right so within that we
import train test split and then you
call the strain test split method or
function or whatever you call that and
pass the data so X is the all the values
of the independent variables and Y is
our labels so you pass x and y and then
you specify what should be
your size of the test data the only one
you need to specify so if you say test
size is 0.25 it is understood that train
size will be 0.75 so you're telling what
should be the ratio of the split so
technically it doesn't nothing prevents
you from giving whatever you like here
so you can give testers 80 and train as
20s whichever way but then there's
normal practices you will have the
training data set would be larger than
the test data set and typically it would
be is 80 20 75 25 or 65 35 something
like that right so that is the second
parameter and this is just to say that
you know the data has to be randomly
split so it shouldn't be like you take
the first 75% and put it in training and
then the next 25% and put it in test so
that so such a thing shouldn't happen so
we first set the state random state so
that the the splitting is done in a very
random way so if they are randomly
picked up the data and then put it into
training and test and then this results
in these four data frames so X train and
X test and y train and white test okay
so that is basically the result it will
now that the splitting is done let's see
how to implement or execute logistic
regression so in logistic regression
what we try to do is try to develop a
model which will classify the data
logistic regression is an algorithm for
supervised learning for performing
classification so logistic regression is
for classification and usually it is
binary classification so binary
classification means there are two
classes so either like a yes/no or for
example customer will buy or will not
buy so that is a binary classification
so that's where we use logistic
regression so let's take a look at the
code how to implement something like
that
using scikit-learn so the first thing is
to import this logic regression sub
module or sub class whatever you call it
and then create an instance of that so
our object is classifier so we are
creating an object by the name this is a
name by the way you can give any name in
our case we are saying classifier
they say classifier is equal to logistic
regression so we are creating an
instance of the logistic
regression variable or class okay and
you can pass a variable or a parameter
rather which is the random state is
equal to zero and once you create the
object which in our case is named
classifier you can then train the object
by calling the method fit so this is
important to note we don't call any
there is no method like train here but
we call what is known as there is a
method called fit
so you're basically by calling the fit
method your training this model and in
order to train the model you need to
pass the training data set so X
underscore train is your independent
variables the set of independent
variables and y underscore train is your
dependent variable or the label so you
pass both of these and call the fit
function or fit method which will
actually result in the training of this
model classifier no this is basically
showing what are the possible parameters
that can be passed or initiated when we
are calling the logistic or the instance
of logistic regression so this is what
you can also look up the help file if
you have installed Python so some of
these are very intuitive but some you
may want to take a look at the details
of what exactly they do alright so
moving on once we train the model by
calling fit then the next step is to
test our model so this is where we will
use the test data unit pay attention
here Here I am calling so there are two
things one is in order to test our data
we have to actually call what is known
as the method known as predict right so
here this is where so the training is
done now is the time for inference isn't
it so we have the model now we want to
check whether our model is working
correctly or not so what do you do you
have your test data
remember we split it 25% of our data was
stored here right we split it into test
and training so that 25% of the data we
passed to and call them at a predict so
that the model will now predict the
values for y right so that's why here we
are calling it as Y underscore predict
and if we display here as I said this is
a logistic regression which is basically
a binary classification so it gives us
the results like yes or no in
this particular case and then you can so
this is what the model has predicted or
model has classified now but we also
know we already have the labels for this
so we need to compare with the existing
labels with the known labels whether
this classification is correct or not so
that is where is the next step which is
basically calculating the accuracy and
so on will come into play okay so in
this case the first thing the most
important thing to notice we do the
prediction using predict and here we are
passing x underscore test and not train
right in this case we did x and y train
so again one more point to be noted here
in case of training we will pass both
the independent variables and also the
dependent variables because the system
has two internally it has to verify that
is what is the training process so what
it will do it will take the X values it
will try to come up with the Y value and
compare with the actual Y value right so
that is what is the training method so
that's why we have to pass both X as
well as Y whereas in case of predict we
don't pass both we only pass because we
are pretending as if this is the actual
data so in actual data you will not have
the labels isn't it so we are just
passing the independent variables and
the system will then come up with the Y
values which we will then okay remember
we also know the actual value so we will
compare this with the actual values and
we will find out whether how accurate
the model is so how do we do that we use
what is known as a confusion matrix so
this is also readily available in the
Python library so we import this
confusion matrix and some of you who
already know machine learning will find
this familiar but those who are new to
machine learning this confusion matrix
is nothing but this matrix this kind of
a matrix which basically tells how many
of them are correctly predicted and how
many of them are incorrectly predicted
so the some of the characteristics let's
quickly spend some time on this
condition matrix itself this the total
numbers out here these are just the
numbers these are like number of
observations then the accuracy is
considered to be highest when de the
numbers or the some of the numbers
across the diagonals is maximum okay
and numbers outside of the diagnosed
should be minimum so which means that if
this model was 100% accurate then the
sum of these two there would have been
only numbers in these two along the
diagonals this would have been zero and
this would have been zero okay so that
is like a hundred percent accurate model
that is very rare but just that you are
aware so just to give an idea okay all
right so once you have the confusion
matrix you then try to calculate the
accuracy which is in a percentage so
there are two things that we can do from
a confusion matrix or that we can
calculate from a confusion matrix one is
the accuracy and the other is the
precision what is the accuracy accuracy
is basically a measure of how many of
the observations have been correctly
predicted okay so let's say this is a
little bit more detailed view of the
confusion matrix it looks very similar
like as we saw in this case right so
this is a two by two matrix that's what
we are seeing here 1827 2 1 0 3 so 1827
2 1 0 3 no but what are these values
that is what is kind of the labels are
shown here in this so there are
altogether 150 observations so as I said
the sum of all these four right 18 plus
27 plus 1 0 3 plus 2 is equal to 150
that's the first thing we have to
observe the sum of all these values will
be equal to the sum of test observations
number of test observations we have 150
test observations because remember we
had about 500 we split that into 25 75
so that is why we have 150 here and
nothing 350 in the training data set
okay so that we get the numbers correct
so that's the first thing now this next
thing is let's take a look at the actual
values this view is the actual view so
there are actually right in the actual
data we have labels
yes and no so as per the actual data
there are 45 observations tagged as know
and similarly there are 105 observations
that are tagged as yes or labeled as yes
okay now I know for the first time when
you are seeing this it may be a little
confusing but just stay with me okay
so this is the actual part of it and
this side tells us the predicted part of
it so our model is predicted and
it has totally predicted 20 of them as
know right so that is what this is
totally twenty of them it has predicted
us know and it has predicted 130 of them
as yes okay I hope this part is clear so
before we go into the middle part let us
first understand what exactly are these
numbers so actually tagged as know there
are 45 total actually tagged as yes
there are 105 and predicted no there are
20 predicted as yes there are 130 this
is the result from our model okay this
is the result from our model and this is
the actual value which we already know
because this is our label data there is
the first thing now
now let us take a look at each of these
individually okay now what are the
options we have once again okay so now
what is happening here let us look at
these these values so this 18 says that
these are actually tagged as know and
the model is also predicted as know
which means this is what is known as a
true positive right or two negative
sorry right which means that our modulus
predicted is it correctly it is negative
because it says no so and it is also
predicted no so it is known as what is
known as true negative okay now let's
come to this side of it that way we are
talking about the diagonals remember I
said most of the values should be in the
diagonals okay so that means these 18
are correctly dead they are labeled as
no and our model as predicted as no so
these are correctly tagged and these are
known as true negative okay similarly if
we come diagonally down there are 103
observations which are labeled as yes
actual values s and our model is also
predicted as yes and these are known as
true positive values positive because of
this yes okay right so what is important
is this is true this is also true so we
have to make sure that the maximum
number of values are in the true section
okay true positive and true negative
that's the reason I said the sum along
the diagonals should be maximum now
let's see if your our model was 100%
accurate this sum in this case it is
only 103 + 100 + 3 plus 18 which is 121
but
if our model was accurate the sum of
these two would have been 150 that means
it's a perfect model okay all right know
what else since we covered these two
let's also cover these two so here this
says that 27 of them were actually
labeled no but our model as predicted as
yes
that means this is wrong right similarly
these are two of them where the actual
value is yes but our model is predicted
as no that means it's a wrong prediction
so you get the point
so therefore along the diagonals are the
correct values whereas in other places
it is all wrong values or wrong
predictions okay
now how do we calculate accuracy from
this information so the way to calculate
accuracy is so we'd say okay there are
total observations are 150 and what are
the correctly predicted values these are
the correctly predicted values which is
18 plus 103 so this will give us our
accuracy so 103 plus 18 which is 121
divided by our total observations which
is 150 is our accuracy which is 0.8 or
we can say it is 80% okay no there is
another concept called precision so
British ssin is given by the formula
true positives divided by the predicted
positives totally predicted positives
okay what do we mean by that which are
the true positives here remember which
are the true positives we just recall we
just talked in the previous slide which
are the true positives you see yeah
so this hundred and three are the true
positives which means that the value is
positive actual value is positive
greater value is also positive so that's
why it's called a true positive so 103
divided by so that is our true positive
103 divided by totally predicted as yes
now what is totally predicted as yes
remember 130 of them I have all together
been predicted as yes not that they are
correctly predicted only under than
three of incorrectly predicted but 130
of them have been predicted as yes so
precision is basically the ratio of
these two out of the totally predicted
how many of them are actually true that
ratio so 1:03 by 130 which is again
about 80 percent is the precision that's
how
your calculate recession so this is just
a simple formula in the term that you
need to remember so accuracy is you need
to take total of true positive and true
negative divided by the total number of
observations where as precision as true
positives divided by the totally
predicted positives okay so that is our
accuracy and precision now what we did
the accuracy calculation was manual but
we can also use some libraries which are
already existing and the functions
within that library so a scikit-learn
provides one such method so for example
accuracy underscore score is one such
method so if you use that and pass your
test and predicted values only the Y you
need to pass right the dependent
variable values so if you pass that it
will calculate it for you so in this
case again as you can see it still
calculates the same which is 80 percent
which we have seen here as well okay so
this can be done using the method great
so that's pretty much what we have done
here before we conclude let me take you
into the code and show you how it
actually looks okay so this is our code
let me run it okay one by one we have
already seen most of the steps and
slides so I will but I will run this in
the actual Jupiter note block some of
you if you are not yet familiar with
Jupiter notebook again there are other
videos we created on how to install
Jupiter notebook and how to set up
Jupiter notebook and so on in this
tutorial also we there was one slide on
how to install Python and Jupiter
notebook if you have not yet done please
do that so that then you can actually
walk through this code while you're
watching this okay so what are we doing
here we are importing the library is
required libraries we call here we have
pandas we have numpy and for
visualization we have matplotlib
and this line is basically reading the
csv file so we have the csv file locally
on our local drive and this is where i'm
checking the data just so that i am
starting with my exploratory analysis
all the data is looking so it looks good
I don't know major missing values or
anything like that so it will display
all the columns and
will show me the first five rows if when
I'm using this head function and then I
want to see a kind of a summary of all
the each of the numerical columns so
that's what I am doing here so these are
the numerical columns and it gives a
summary like how many observations are
there what is the mean standard
deviation minimum maximum and so on and
so forth for each of them and then you
can do some visualization so this is the
visualization for this okay the next
step is to view the data data
visualization and we will do that using
a histogram for a couple of these
columns so in this case I'm taking a
look at the loan amount and if I create
a histogram it displays the data here in
the form of a histogram one thing that
we gather from this as I mentioned in
the slides as well as how the data is
kind of scattered so while most of the
values are in this range 0 to 300 range
there are a few extreme values around
the 700 range so that is one information
we get from this histogram similarly for
the applicant income if we draw
histogram something similar we can see
that while most of the values are in
this range 0 to 20,000 range there are a
few in the range of 80 thousand and
probably sixty-five thousand and so on
ok so the next step is to perform data
wrangling where we will check if any
data is missing and how to fill those
missing values and so on so in this case
we will just check for all the columns
how many data or how many entries are
there that missing values this is the
results alone ID has all the columns or
all the cells filled gender has 13
missing values marital status has three
missing values and so on and so forth
loan amount as 21 and this is what we
are going to show you how to remove
these missing values so when you have
missing values as I mentioned in during
the slides there are a couple of ways of
handling that one is you can completely
remove those or you fill in with some
meaningful values so in this case we
will fill the missing values with the
mean value of the loan amount so let's
go ahead and do that and now if we check
here up now loan amount number of
missing values is 0 because what we did
was for all these 21
cells where the values were missing we
filled with the mean value of the loan
AMA so now there are no more missing
values for loan amount we can do this
for other columns as well but this was
just one example so we have shown it
here okay so we will run this for credit
history and loan amount term as well and
then if we calculate the mean of pretty
much all the numerical columns that's
the method call so DF dot mean will give
us the mean of all the numerical values
and another thing that we can do is we
want to find out what are the data types
of each of these columns so you can call
D F dot d types and get the data types
of course it may not be that very useful
most of the cases is an object but for
example this one it shows as in 64 and
float 64 and so on and so forth now in
addition to doing the exploratory data
analysis we can do some machine learning
activity as well so in this case we are
going to do logistic regression so this
is the example that I have shown you in
the slides as well this is the actual
code for that all right so the first
step here is to import the libraries and
then the next step is to separate the
independent variables and the dependent
variables so X is our independent
variable and Y is our dependent variable
so we separate the data into two parts
and this will be our target as well
right so that's how we separate it now
we have to split the data into training
and test datasets as I mentioned in the
during the slides we use the Train test
split method and when we call this and
pass the independent variables and the
dependent variables and we specify the
test size to be 0.25 which means the
training size will be 0.75 which is
nothing but you split the data into
training data set which is 75% and test
data set in which is 25% ok so once you
split that you will have all your
independent variables data in extreme
the training data which is 75% of it
similarly in dependent variables or test
will be in
underscore test and dependent variable
strain will be invalid under score train
and dependent variable test will be
Wireless contest once we do this we have
to do a small exercise for scaling
remember we had some data which was kind
of very scattered there were some
extreme values and so on so this will
take care of that so that the data is
normalized so that before we pass to our
algorithm the data is normalized so that
the performance will be much better the
next step is to create the instance of
logistic regression object so that's
what we are doing here
so classifier is our logistic regression
instance right classifier is equal to
logistic regression we are saying so one
instance of velocity regression is
created and then we call the training
method the name of the method actually
is fit but what it is doing is it is
taking the training data X is the
training data or the independent
variables and Y is the dependent
variables so we are taking both of these
and the model gets trained so the method
for calling the training is fit okay so
it gives us the output and then once we
are done with the training we do the
testing and once again just to recall in
the slides when I was showing you the
slides also I mentioned we don't pass Y
here while we are testing while for
training we do pass white but right so
for fit we are passing x and y but for
test we are only passing X and something
you need to observe because Y will be
calculated by the model and we will then
compare that with the known value of Y
to measure the accuracy so that's what
we will do here and the method that is
called here is predict so this will
basically create or predict the values
of Y now we have in this case a binary
classification so the outputs are yes or
no Y indicates yes and n indicates no so
Y or n is the output now how do we
measure the accuracy as we have seen
earlier I described how confusion matrix
works and how we can use confusion
matrix for calculating the accuracy
that's what we are seeing here
so this is the confusion matrix and then
you want to do the measure the accuracy
you can directly use this method I
we find that it is 80% so we in the
slides we have seen when we calculate
manually as well we get an accuracy of
80% okay let's go back to our slides and
do a summary so what we have done in the
session we talked about what is data
science and why python is being used why
it is becoming so popular how to install
Python and we talked about the various
libraries in Python like panis I PI
numpy and so on and then we took a
couple of examples and wrote the code
and demonstrated the code for performing
exploratory analysis and performing data
wrangling or data manipulation and then
we at the end we did one example of
machine learning using scikit-learn
library and perform the logistic
regression example so with that we come
to the end of the session if you have
any queries comments please put them
below and you can also give your email
id so that we can get back to you if you
have any questions I hope you enjoyed
the session thank you very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here